an American hunter is pushing back
against her critics after photos of her
next to a giraffe she killed in South
Africa triggered global outrage test
Thompson tally tell CBS this morning she
killed the old bull giraffe to prevent
it from attacking younger giraffes she
said quote this is called conservation
through game management David beg no
shows us why some conservationists
aren't buying her explanation David good
morning Anthony good morning you know
the situations being compared to Cecil
the lion
remember that iconic big cat that was
hunted down by Minnesota Dennis back in
2015 now even though the giraffe in this
case wasn't world-famous like Cecil the
response from animal lovers has been
equally intense conservationists fear
that one of the greatest beasts of the
African savannah could soon face
extinction fewer than 100 thousand
giraffes remain on the entire planet so
when these pictures surfaced of tests
Thompson Tali posing with a giraffe she
just killed conservationists were
sickened it's shocking that anyone would
take joy or pleasure in killing a
beautiful and graceful animal like a
giraffe it was an obscure news website
called
Africa Land that posted the pictures on
Twitter describing Talley is a white
American Savage who is partly a
Neanderthal actress Debra Messing said
she was a vile heartless selfish
murderer
people will say stuff you know behind a
computer screen they never say to your
face Paul Baba's is president of the
hunting advocacy group Safari Club
International Tess Thompson tally is
also a member she was winning in South
Africa and giraffes are legal to hunting
South Africa in a statement tally said
the giraffe she killed last year was
over 18 years old and beyond breeding
age yet had killed three younger Bulls
now that the giraffe is gone the younger
Bulls are able to breed she said
according to Bob as the trophy fee for a
giraffe is about two to three thousand
dollars per animal he says because money
from legal hunting helps support the
local community it provides an incentive
to make sure big-game animals don't
become extinct without that the poachers
will come in and kill the animals
indiscriminately
which is very unfortunate Tally's prey
was a south african giraffe that had a
black coat due to its age it's a
subspecies that's population is up
actually 167 percent since 1979 to more
than 21,000 but the giraffe population
overall has declined as much as 40
percent iris Howe with Humane Society
International insists that wildlife
tourism is far more beneficial for the
animals and local communities than
trophy hunting US imports you know
almost four thousand giraffe trophies
for the last ten years probably everyday
there's a giraffe being killed and
imported into the US as hunting trophy
now according to m'avez that hunting
advocate we spoke to Tali ate some of
the giraffes meat during the hunting
trip but gave most of it away to feed
more than 200 local villagers including
children at an orphanage he was not able
to prove that that happened and we
cannot independently confirm it so many
questions here I mean I have to say I
have trouble with this whole idea of
posing with an animal you just yeah I
don't understand why you want to do I
don't either I just threw up in my mouth
and then when you just give that tag
that you gave it the more you hear the
worse it gets I didn't even know that
people hunted giraffes number one yeah
growing up in Texas like nowhere and I
did look big game hunting is not foreign
yeah but I may be ignorant Lee didn't
know the giraffes yeah yeah thank you
David you believe it